North Korea is the regime is a religion
right the capital religion so what's
interesting about why they fear
Christianity so much the kimer song was
really raised in a Christian family and
Pyongyang used to be a very thriving
Christian a time where there are a lot
of missionaries came from the West
and then Kim your son when he became a
dictator he copied the Bible he copied
Ten Commandments and he said I love you
so much I'm giving you my son Kim zonia
his body dies but his spirit is with us
all the time that's how he knows our
thoughts what we think and that's how
people are even afraid to think and
because he copied the Bible if people
read the actual Bible that was written
many thousands of years before him we're
gonna know that he's the fake
that's why he fears a Christian is so
much more
but there are no existence of any
religion officially say they allow like
freedom of religion but in reality
nobody can